منذ بدا عرض حلقاتي على منصه شاهد منذ
الاول من ديسمبر الجاري استطاع مسلسل اخر
دور ان يتصدر قائمه الاعمال اكثر مشاهده
بعدما نال العمل درامي اعجاب العديد من
محبي الغموض والاثاره اخر دور هو مسلسل
تشويق واثاره مصريه تدور احداثه حول فتاه
تسكن في احد العقارات في الدور الاخير
والسعرض العمل علاقتها بالجيران والمشاكل
التي يتعرضون لها على المستوى الشخصي الى
ان تحدث جريمه قتل تقلب الاحداث راس على
ويعتبر المسلسل من الاعمال القصيره فهو
ويتكون من اثنتين 10 حلقه المسلسل من
اخراج حسين المنباوي وبتوله دينا الشربيني
احمد بدير ميمي جمال احمد خالد صالح ونهى
عابدين ومريم الخشب ومين افضل من انه يشرح
لنا غير يوسف زين الدين المتحدث من فريق
شاهدنا الينا في الاستديو يسعد هالصباح
وقت ما طلع اخر دور وصار واصل سبع حلقات
ومكسر الدنيا على السوشيال ميديا
على السباق الدرامي بشكل عام وهو محتل
المراكز الاولى المركز الاول لهلا بمصر
والمركز الثالث بشكل عام فعم نحكي احنا
مسلسل قصه الاثاره والغموض كثير بتشد
المشاهده يعني احنا عم نحكي عن جريمه قتل
ودائما ان السؤال
فهذا الشيء بشد كثير الناس يعني دائما
بتصير انت بتتحللي طيب اصحابها ناس بره
مين بيهددها وغيره فهذا الاشياء كلها مع
بعض بتخلي الانسان او المشاهد بيحب انه
يحضر ويتعلق اكثر من المسلسل
[موسيقى]
هذه الشقه اللي هي موجوده في اخر دور
باعجاب كثير من الناس وانت قبل الهواء كنت
عم بتقول لي شغله عن هذه الشقه
اللي عم بيمثلوا فيها والنعم بيعملوا فيها
المشاهد كلها هي عباره عن
استديو يعني استوديو مركب كرومه يعني احنا
كمان في عندنا مشاهد من كواليس راح نشوفهم
كمان شوي يعني كله عباره عن تركيب جرافيكس
فاحبوا انهم يعملوا منظر حلو جميل
عادي ولكن الفكره انه دائما لما انت بدك
تعملي قصه قويه تشد المشاهد ذات الوقت
كمان عم تعملي مشهد جميل
طيب خلينا كمان نشوف مع بعض في مسلسل كمان
حبيبي كثير اعجاب وخصوصا الجزء الثاني
اللي راح يطلع قريبا مسلسل موضوع عائد طيب
يوسف هل راح يكون الموضوع عائلي بالجزء
الثاني بنفس اهميه تالق الجزء الاول
مسلسلات الجزء الاول
كان في تحدي ان احنا نعمل جزء ثاني من
اعمال شهد الاصليه
اا التحدي انتقل بانهم يطلعوا بقصه تكمل
القصه الاولى ولكن وين هتاخذنا هلا في
مفاجاه طبعا راح تكون جديد في المسلسل
بجزء الثاني انه راح نشوف تصوير بين مصر
بلغاريا ليه بلغاريا راح يكون في مفاجاه
اوكي هنعرف ليش في بلغاري بس ولكن انا
حبيت اختصر المسلسل بجمله انه انه الانسان
بصعب بدون تفكير توفير السعاده دائما
لاهله واحبائه ولكن لما بيعرف انه موعد
رحيله قرب بفكر هل اللي تركه كافي اه ولا
لا بس هيك انت قلبتها كثير دراما يعني
احنا كنا اكثر ميالين
اكيد مع ماجد
وطيب يوسف كمان سريع عن نلاحظ دائما في
توجه للاعمال القصيره بشكل عام شوف
الاعمال القصيره الحلو فيها عم بتشد لك
الاحداث ايقاع اسرع انت عم تطلعي من قالب
المسلمات 30 حلقه احنا بنسميها هلا في
مسلسلات تركيه حلقه جميله جدا واكثر كمان
اوكي بس ولكن مسلسلات السريعه حتى احنا
بالعصر اللي عايشين فيها هلا بدك تحضري
مسلسل بالويك انك تخلصيه سريع سريع بالذات
اللي ما عم يحضر مثلا اذا مثلا نحكي
اسبوعيا وبتستني المسلسل كله يخلص هون
نحنا عم نحكي عن 12 حلقه كمان احنا بنشكرك
جزيلا للشكر
يا يوسف